Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Soll ich vorangehen?
- Guten Tag miteinander.
Guten Tag.
- Willkommen.
Ja, guten Tag. Grüss Gott.
- Guten Tag.
* Fliessende Musik *
André Hoffmann und Jörg Duschmalé -
zwei der reichsten Schweizer.
Seit 125 Jahren ist ihre Familie
in Besitz von Roche,
dem weltgrössten Pharmakonzern.
Das macht schon auch stolz.
Es ist also schon etwas
ganz besonders Tolles.
Vielleicht schon
eine gewisse Aggressivität im Bau.
Aber es ist halt
eine wichtige Firma,
und die muss schon irgendwie
ein Zeichen setzen.
Ein wuchtiges Zeichen.
Mächtig und dominant.
Die Roche-Türme
beherrschen die Basler Skyline.
Sie sind die höchsten Gebäude
der Schweiz, 205 und 178 m hoch.
Sie haben das Münster
als Wahrzeichen der Stadt abgelöst.
Roche erzielte im letzten Jahr
rund 60 Mrd. Fr. Umsatz
und einen Gewinn von 15 Mrd. Fr.
Entscheidend ist, dass wir wissen,
was gut für die Firma ist.
Und was gut für die Firma ist, ist
letztlich auch gut für die Familie.
Und nicht: Was gut für die Familie
ist, ist es auch für die Firma.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt.
Der Basler Konzern
beschäftigt 100'000 Angestellte
in über 100 Ländern.
Auch ein Unternehmen wie Roche
ist nicht unfehlbar.
Der Druck ist gross.
Wir sind an der Börse kotiert.
Wir müssen die kurzfristigen
Erwartungen befriedigen.
Der Börsenwert von Roche
diesen Sommer: 320 Mrd. Fr.
Das wertvollste
Unternehmen der Schweiz
ist im Besitz einer Basler Familie.
* Pulsierende, drängende Musik *
André Hoffmann
ist ein Urenkel des Firmengründers.
Jörg Duschmalé
vertritt die fünfte Generation
und den Familienzweig der Oeris.
Der Weltkonzern
bestimmt das Leben der Roche-Erben.
Wir benutzen immer dasselbe Bild:
Wenn wir zu Abend assen, war immer
ein Stück von Roche am Tisch.
Man sprach immer darüber.
Und das ist halt eine Tatsache.
Das ist halt ein Teil des Alltags.
Die beiden vertreten die Familie
im Verwaltungsrat des Konzerns.
Das bringt selbstverständlich
eine gewisse Verantwortung mit sich.
Aber ich empfinde es auch
als Privileg,
diese Verantwortung übernehmen
und weitertragen zu dürfen.
Also wie ein Familienschmuckstück,
das man vielleicht irgendwann
an einem Familienfest kriegt
und dann einmal der nächsten
Generation weitergeben möchte.
Es ist nicht nur ein Privileg,
es ist auch eine Aufgabe.
Und die nehmen wir ernst.
Sind wir angekommen?
* Lachen *
* Langsame, fliessende Melodie *
Er muss es für die Familie
und für die Aktionäre richten:
Roche-Chef Severin Schwan, der am
besten bezahlte Manager der Schweiz.
Jeden Tag
verdient er rund 40'000 Fr.
Mitte Juli
geht es aber um andere Zahlen.
Der Konzernchef präsentiert heute
das Halbjahresergebnis.
Wie immer bei gutem Wetter
kommt er mit dem Elektrorad.
Ich wohne ja nicht weit von hier,
und da geniesse ich eigentlich
nur die Natur.
In der Früh, v.a. heute,
wenn es schon sehr früh losgeht,
wenn es so ruhig ist ...
Es ist eigentlich Entspannung,
bevor es dann so richtig losgeht.
Also, auf geht's.
Der ganze Tag ist minutiös geplant.
Analysten und Journalisten
wollen vom CEO wissen,
wie sich Roche
in der Pandemie schlägt.
Erstmals darf ein Fernsehteam
Severin Schwan begleiten -
aber nicht überallhin.
Sein Büro ist tabu,
wie auch sein Privatleben.
Der erste Termin:
Telefonkonferenz mit den wichtigsten
internationalen Finanzmedien.
"Wall Street Journal",
Reuters, "Financial Times".
Im Hintergrund der One-Man-Show:
die Mediensprecher.
Legen wir los. Wie viele
haben sich schon angemeldet?
(Mann) Zehn.
Jedes Quartal muss er liefern.
Seine Aussagen
können den Aktienkurs beeinflussen
und so Milliarden an Börsenwert
vernichten oder generieren.
Sie sind ein Familienunternehmen.
Haben Sie da weniger Druck?
Ich glaube,
wir haben das Beste beider Welten.
Auf der einen Seite haben wir na-
türlich den Druck der Kapitalmärkte
und müssen uns den Fragen stellen.
Auf der anderen Seite
haben wir aber auch das Privileg,
dass wir wirklich
sehr langfristig denken
und auch einmal
Entscheidungen treffen können,
die sich erst in fünf, zehn
oder vielleicht sogar erst
in 15 oder 20 Jahren auszahlen.
Es folgen TV-Interviews
mit CNBC und Bloomberg.
Alles muss stimmen.
Das Ding muss ein bisschen
höher rauf. Es muss höher.
(Mann) Good morning.
This is CNBC. Can you hear me?
I can hear you well. Is it okay?
It is looking nice. Thank you.
- Okay, great. Excellent.
Der Umsatz mit Medikamenten
ist um 3 % gesunken,
doch die Coronapandemie
interessiert deutlich mehr.
Thank you, thanks a lot.
Okay.
- Zufrieden?
Ja, es waren die erwarteten Fragen.
Wann ist das nächste?
4 Min.? Okay.
Heute geht es ja wirklich
getaktet voran.
Wir haben insgesamt
gute Ergebnisse geliefert.
Die Strategie auch im Gespräch
mit Schweizer Medien:
Positives hervorheben,
Negatives relativieren,
etwa dass Roche wegen Patentabläufen
bei Krebsmedikamenten
seit Jahren
Milliarden an Umsatz verliert.
Der Umsatz
ist ja weiter zurückgegangen.
Mit welchen Verlusten rechnen Sie da
in den nächsten Jahren?
Wir gehen jetzt davon aus,
dass diese Auswirkungen
bereits im zweiten Halbjahr
deutlich abnehmen werden.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist wirklich
der Erfolg der neuen Produkte.
Wir können diese Ausfälle
der älteren Produkte
durch diese neuen Produkte
kompensieren.
Der 54-jährige Tiroler
kam direkt nach dem Studium zu Roche
und ist mittlerweile auch Schweizer.
Haben Sie alles?
Ja, sehr gut. Okay, gut. Perfekt.
Inwiefern gehören Sie zur Familie?
Sie sind doch jetzt immerhin schon
28 Jahre dabei und 13 Jahre CEO.
Ja, mein ganzes Berufsleben
ist geprägt von Roche,
und in dem Sinne bin ich natürlich
schon Teil der Roche-Familie.
Aber man darf seine eigene Rolle
auch nicht überschätzen.
Roche gibt's schon seit 125 Jahren,
und sie wird von einer Generation
zur nächsten getragen.
Roche begann vor 125 Jahren
hier in Kleinbasel
mit einer klaren Strategie:
Medikamente industriell zu fertigen,
diese mit viel Marketing zu verkaufen
und schnell
international zu expandieren.
Über all die Jahre
fusionierte Roche zudem nie,
blieb immer eigenständig -
ganz im Sinne der Familie.
Das Firmenarchiv
dokumentiert jedes Detail.
Aufbewahrt
werden auch spezielle Objekte
im Zusammenhang mit
erfolgreichen Produkten.
Good old days.
* Lachen *
Oder die ungewöhnliche Sponsoring-
anfrage eines Fussballklubs.
(Mann)
Etwas, was wir nie gesponsert haben:
Manchester United
mit dem Shirt Nr. 7
von Cristiano Ronaldo
und David Beckham.
Ich habe mich immer gewundert,
dass sich Herr Schwan
nie dafür interessiert hat.
Das kam immer sofort ins Archiv,
diese Sponsoringanfragen.
Das beruhigt mich schon.
Dass er sich nicht
unter Vertrag nehmen liess.
Am Anfang von Roche
stand das Desinfektionsmittel Airol.
Mit Vitaminen wurde das Unternehmen
ab den 1930er-Jahren weltweit gross.
Valium
hiess der nächste Kassenschlager.
Das Beruhigungsmittel mit dem Ruf
einer Gesellschaftsdroge
war ab 1968 über ein Jahrzehnt das
meistverkaufte Medikament der Welt.
Viele andere Produkte
erlangen grosse Bekanntheit:
die Wundsalbe Bepanthen
oder Pantene zur Haarpflege.
Roche hat die meisten aber
längst abgestossen
und verkauft nur noch
rezeptpflichtige
und v.a. margenträchtigere
Medikamente
wie das Schlafmittel Dormicum,
Lariam gegen Malaria
oder das Grippemittel Tamiflu, dessen
Wirkung bis heute umstritten ist.
Die Bestseller der letzten Jahre
waren die drei Krebsmittel
Herceptin, Avastin und MabThera.
Ihre Patente
sind nun aber abgelaufen.
Am meisten in die Kasse
spült heute das Multiple-
Sklerose-Medikament Ocrevus -
dieses Jahr rund 5 Mrd. Fr.
oder 8 % des Konzernumsatzes.
Das ist der allererste
gedruckte Geschäftsbericht.
Sie sehen:
Das war sehr übersichtlich
und auf seine Art und Weise
auch transparenter als heute.
Wobei nicht sehr viel drinstand.
Es gab aber eine Bilanz und eine
Erfolgsrechnung, wie man das macht.
Und die Firma
schnitt mit einem kleinen Gewinn ab.
Das freut uns natürlich.
* Lachen *
Und dieses Bild
ist natürlich in jedem ...
Das ist das legendäre Bild, genau.
Das Hochzeitsfoto von Fritz
und Adele Hoffmann-La Roche.
Fritz Hoffmann-La Roche
gründete die Firma 1896.
Sohn Emanuel folgte ihm,
starb aber früh.
Seine Frau Maja Stehlin heiratete
den Dirigenten Paul Sacher.
In den nachfolgenden Generationen
nahm die Familie nur noch
im Verwaltungsrat Einsitz.
Durch die Heirat von Vera Hoffmann
mit Jakob Oeri
bildete sich der Oeri-Familienzweig.
Er besteht in der vierten Generation
aus fünf Geschwistern.
Da nur zwei Geschwister Kinder haben,
schrumpft die fünfte Generation
der Oeris auf nur vier Mitglieder.
Bei den Hoffmanns hat Luc vier
Kinder, diese wiederum haben acht.
Zwei Mitglieder des Hoffmann-Zweigs
starben früh.
Mittlerweile sind Kinder der sechsten
Generation zur Welt gekommen.
Insgesamt ist die Anzahl der Erben
aber immer noch relativ klein -
mit ein Grund dafür,
warum Roche noch in Familienhand ist.
Ein anderer Grund:
15 Mitglieder
sind in einem Familienpool vereint,
um mit einer Stimme zu sprechen.
Vertreter des Familienpools
im Verwaltungsrat
sind André Hoffmann
und Jörg Duschmalé.
Sie sind in einem Pool organisiert.
Wie funktioniert das?
Wie spricht man sich da ab?
Also,
wie der Pool selbst funktioniert,
wollen wir
nicht unbedingt veröffentlichen.
Aber wir treffen uns, wir reden.
Wir sind derselben Meinung.
Es ist natürlich nicht etwas,
was spontan kommt.
Man muss daran arbeiten.
Man muss immer wieder
diesen Kontakt suchen,
um die verschiedenen Interessen
zu verstehen und zu befriedigen.
Wir haben eine Whatsapp-Gruppe.
Wollen wir das sagen?
Ja, wir kommunizieren von Zeit zu
Zeit mit Whatsapp. Wir sind modern.
Das funktioniert?
- Uff. Manchmal.
Gegen aussen treten
ausschliesslich diese beiden auf,
wenn auch widerwillig und selten.
Zum 125-Jahre-Jubiläum ihres Konzerns
machen sie eine Ausnahme
und geben eine Medienkonferenz.
Vorgängig
werden sie vom Medienteam gebrieft.
(Frau) Es haben sich insgesamt
36 Journalisten angemeldet.
Das sind sehr viele.
- Ja.
Das ist quasi die gesamte Abdeckung
der Schweiz und Deutschlands.
(Mann) Eine Frage, die ich sicher
erwarte, ist quasi Ihre Nachfolge.
Jörg ist aus der fünften Generation,
da hat die Ablösung
schon stattgefunden.
Wie sehen Sie das?
Wie planen Sie das?
Meine übliche Antwort ist, zu sagen,
dass mein Grossvater sich zurückzog,
als er 90 Jahre alt war.
Ich habe
noch mind. 30 Jahre vor mir.
Dann sicher auch die Frage nach
Momenten in der Roche-Geschichte,
sei es Seveso, seien es andere
kritische Momente in der Geschichte.
Wie ist da Ihre Position?
Wie haben Sie das wahrgenommen?
Auch z.B. mit dem Vitaminkartell.
Grosse Gewinne, grosse Margen,
Severins hoher Lohn usw.
Das sind Klassiker,
die hattest du ja auch.
Die Probleme und Skandale von Roche,
z.B. die Seveso-Katastrophe von 1976.
Bei der Roche-Tochter Icmesa im
italienischen Seveso trat Dioxin aus.
Hunderte Menschen, v.a. Kinder,
erlitten Hautverletzungen.
80'000 Tiere starben.
Anstatt die Bevölkerung
schnell zu warnen,
vertuschte Roche den Unfall zunächst
und spielte ihn dann herunter.
Ein anderer Skandal:
das Vitaminkartell.
Der Basler Roche-Konzern
ist in den USA
gehörig an die Kasse gekommen.
Er zahlt in einem Vergleich mit
dem amerikanischen Justizdepartement
eine Rekordbusse von 750 Mio. Fr.
Der Basler Konzern
wurde beschuldigt,
zusammen mit anderen
Vitaminherstellern
zwischen 1990 und 1999 Preis-
absprachen vorgenommen zu haben.
Die EU hat den Basler Pharmakonzern
mit einer Rekordbusse bestraft.
Nach der Kartellbehörde präsentieren
jetzt auch private Kläger,
die als Firmenkunden
geschädigt wurden,
die Rechnung
für das Vitamingeschäft.
* Düstere, pulsierende Musik *
Herr Hoffmann,
mögen Sie solche Auftritte?
Mein Herz klopft im Moment.
Ich mache mir auch Sorgen,
weil Sie von den Medien sind.
Es hat aber auch
einen unglaublichen Hebeleffekt:
Wenn wir unsere Message
rausbringen können, ist das super.
Die Hauptbotschaft für die Medien
ist klar:
Die Besitzerfamilie und Roche
gehören zusammen.
Nachzulesen auch
in der neuen Historie,
die der Konzern für das Jubiläum
in Auftrag gegeben hat.
Historisch
ist auch die Medienkonferenz.
Zum ersten Mal treten
die beiden Erben gemeinsam auf.
Einen wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Ich heisse Sie
sehr herzlich willkommen.
André, wenn du
diese 8 kg Bücher hier so siehst,
was bedeutet das für dich?
Wenn ich diese Bücher sehe,
bin ich natürlich sehr aufgeregt.
Das ist so eine Überschwemmung
von Stolz, die da aufkommt.
Ja, ich kann dieses Gefühl von Stolz
eigentlich nur unterstreichen.
Die Firma existiert nicht,
um Geld zu machen,
sondern, um Menschen zu helfen.
- Es geht um die Sache.
Ja.
- Die Sache ist im Zentrum.
Es geht nicht
um Einzelne in der Familie.
Wie erwartet, werden auch die
Skandale der Vergangenheit zum Thema.
Das Vitaminkartell
war nicht unsere schönste Stunde.
Ich war da wirklich noch ein Kind.
Aber ich erinnere mich daran,
wie das
am Esstisch zu Hause ein Thema war,
wie man sich als Familie
dafür geschämt hat,
dass so etwas in unserem Unternehmen
passieren konnte.
Wir sind umso überzeugter
daraus hervorgegangen,
dass wir dafür sorgen wollen,
dass so etwas nicht mehr vorkommt.
Nach über 2 Std. Rede und Antwort
zeigen sich
die Roche-Erben zufrieden.
Sie konnten ihre Botschaft anbringen.
Sie haben uns gut vorbereitet.
Dass die Familie den Konzern
überhaupt kontrollieren kann,
verdankt sie
einer altmodischen Kapitalstruktur.
Der Konzern
hat zwei Arten von Anteilsscheinen
mit unterschiedlichen Rechten.
Die Besitzer von Genussscheinen
erhalten zwar eine Dividende,
sie haben aber kein Stimmrecht
an der Generalversammlung.
Die Besitzer von Inhaberaktien
hingegen erhalten eine Dividende
und können über die Firma bestimmen.
Darum sind die Genussscheine,
obwohl es davon viermal mehr gibt,
nicht relevant
für die Kontrolle des Konzerns.
Entscheidend sind die Inhaberaktien.
45 % sind im Besitz des Aktionärs-
pools der Familien Oeri-Hoffmann.
5,1 % Prozent gehören Maja Oeri,
die den Pool verlassen hat,
aber in der Regel
mit der Familie stimmt.
So können die Roche-Erben
den Konzern kontrollieren.
33,3 % gehören
der Basler Konkurrentin Novartis.
Der Rest der Inhaberaktien
ist im sog. Streubesitz.
Jetzt hat Novartis 33 %.
Stört Sie das? Oder wie ist das?
Ignorieren Sie das einfach?
Ignorieren ist nie eine gute Lösung.
Aber ich wache nachts nicht auf,
um darüber nachzudenken.
Ist das gar kein Thema?
Wir sind gute Nachbarn
in der Stadt Basel.
Die Stadt Basel
ist uns allen wichtig.
Novartis, ebenfalls einer
der grössten Pharmakonzerne der Welt.
Der damalige Chef Daniel Vasella
machte Avancen für eine Fusion.
Die Roche-Familie
wollte aber nichts davon wissen.
Daniel Vasella blitzte ab.
Gleich erging es zuvor Martin Ebner.
Der Financier
kaufte um die Jahrtausendwende
20 % der Roche-Aktien und forderte so
einen Verwaltungsratssitz
und die Schaffung
einer Einheitsaktie.
Auch er biss auf Granit.
An der Roche-Generalversammlung
machte André Hoffmann,
schon damals Familienvertreter,
klar, wer das Sagen hat.
Wir kamen zum Schluss, dass er dem
Verwaltungsrat nicht viel bringt,
und haben ihm das auch
entsprechend kommuniziert.
Hat das auch damit zu tun,
dass er über die Medien
den Verwaltungsrat, Sie
und Ihre Familie kritisiert hat?
Das hat nicht sehr geholfen.
Martin Ebner gab auf und
verkaufte seine Aktien an Novartis.
Die Roche-Erben
kontrollieren den Konzern
aber nicht nur
über die Generalversammlung,
sondern auch über ihre
beiden Vertreter im Verwaltungsrat.
Wie sehen Sie Ihre Rolle
im Verwaltungsrat?
Ich präsidiere
das Entschädigungskomitee
und das Komitee für Nachhaltigkeit.
Ich bin auch Teil
des Präsidentialausschusses,
und da versuchen wir,
eine direktere Rolle zu übernehmen.
Aber wir sind ganz klar
non-executive.
Unsere Rolle ist nicht,
zu bestimmen, was die Firma macht,
sondern zu versichern,
dass sie es im richtigen Sinn macht.
Sechsmal pro Jahr trifft sich
der zwölfköpfige Verwaltungsrat -
meist in Basel.
Christoph Franz, der ehemalige
SWISS- und Lufthansa-Chef,
ist Verwaltungsratspräsident.
Also, guten Morgen. Seid ihr alle
schon frei und getestet?
Ich mache es so.
- Gut.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Zweimal getestet -
am Samstag, in Hongkong.
Ich bin so durchgetestet.
Im Gremium sitzen Wirtschaftsgrössen
wie Nestlé-Präsident Paul Bulcke,
Swiss-Life-Chef Patrick Frost
und Beraterin Claudia Süssmuth,
Tochter von Ex-Bundestagspräsidentin
Rita Süssmuth.
Und die beiden Familienvertreter.
Ich glaube, die Familie
hat primär das Interesse,
bei Führungsfunktionen
involviert zu sein.
So würde ich es mal sagen.
Da geht es natürlich sehr stark
um die Frage
der Verwaltungsratsmitglieder,
insbesondere
des Verwaltungsratspräsidenten.
Es geht um die Frage,
wer der CEO des Unternehmens ist -
und sicherlich auch um die
eine oder andere Schlüsselposition
in der Geschäftsleitung.
A very warm welcome
to today's board meeting.
Can you take over, Severin?
Zum Verwaltungsrat
gehört auch Severin Schwan.
André Hoffmann ist Vizepräsident
und seit 25 Jahren dabei,
Jörg Duschmalé seit gut einem Jahr.
... delayed us for one year.
There is another
very interesting ...
Jörg Duschmalé
vertritt den Oeri-Familienzweig.
Der 37-Jährige
ist Sohn von Sabine Oeri,
die seit der Heirat
Duschmalé heisst.
Bis 2018 forschte der promovierte
Chemiker fünf Jahre bei Roche,
danach hörte er wegen
seines Verwaltungsratsmandates auf.
Heute besucht er
einen ehemaligen Kollegen.
Schön, wieder mal hier zu sein.
- Ja, gleichfalls.
Funktioniert meine Maschine noch?
- Sicher. Wir tragen Sorge.
Pass damit auf.
- Ja, sicher.
Nein, sie funktioniert noch.
- Super.
Wie war es mit ihm? Er ist ja
Firmenbesitzer. War das kein Thema?
Ich habe ihn höchstens hochgenommen.
Wenn er irgendetwas kaputt machte,
sagte ich:
"Du bezahlst das sowieso selbst."
Sonst haben wir das
nie direkt angesprochen.
Welcome back.
- Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Willst du eine grosse Schutzbrille?
- Ja, gerne. Sehr gut.
Mein Schreibtisch ist noch frei,
sagst du?
Die Aussicht musste leiden,
weil ich ein wenig Platz brauchte,
aber sonst ...
- Das sehe ich.
Du könntest gleich wieder
mit der Arbeit beginnen.- Direkt.
Ah, ja, da sind sogar noch
die Schläuche,
die ich während Telefonkonferenzen
geknetet habe.
Ja, und das Gerät steht immer noch
hier hinten.- Sehr gut.
Diese Maschine dient der Synthese
von Oligonukleotiden.
Das sind im Grunde genommen
kurze DNA-Sequenzen.
D.h., das ist ein bisschen
wie ein Drucker.
Darf ich ihn öffnen?
- Ja, ja.
Diese Schläuche
haben im Grunde genommen
überall dort einen Ausgang.
So werden dann
die verschiedenen Reagenzien,
die Sie hier sehen,
wie es nötig ist
in die einzelnen
Reaktionsgefässe gepumpt.
Ich merke, wie Sie gerade aufgehen.
Ist das Ihr Herzblut?
Ja, ich habe gerne
mit meinen Fingern gearbeitet
und mir hier ein bisschen
meine Finger dreckig gemacht.
Und jetzt würden Sie gerne wieder mal
ins Labor gehen und Hand anlegen?
Nein, eigentlich war das wirklich
einfach eine gute Zeit.
Ich könnte ab und zu Hilfe brauchen.
- Vielleicht komme ich drauf zurück.
Es war eine gute Zeit.
Jetzt ist eine andere Zeit,
in der ich auch aufgehe.
War er ein geschickter Forscher?
- Ja.
Er war auch sehr verbissen.
Er wollte, dass es funktioniert.
Er blieb dran sitzen und sagte:
"Das muss irgendwie gehen."
Es ist schön, dass du das sagst.
Ich habe schon auch das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht der ungeschickteste
Chemiker aller Zeiten war.
Nein, nein, definitiv nicht.
Rotkreuz, der andere grosse Standort
von Roche in der Schweiz.
Rund 3'000 Personen arbeiten hier
für die Diagnostiksparte.
Sie ist Severin Schwans alte Liebe.
Bevor er Konzernchef wurde,
leitete er diese Sparte.
Sie erlebt wegen Corona
einen grossen Aufschwung.
* Stimmengewirr *
Nein, nein gross.
Geben Sie mir gleich gross.
Es ist sehr nett von Ihnen,
dass Sie mittel erwarten,
aber ich befürchte,
ich brauche gross.
* Lachen *
Roche entwickelt hier Diagnosegeräte.
Schon kurz nach Ausbruch der Pandemie
konnten sie Corona-PCR-Tests machen.
Dafür gab es Lob von Donald Trump
und anderen Regierungschefs.
Diese riefen Severin Schwan
sogar persönlich an.
Ohne Namen zu nennen ...
Es ist schon interessant,
wenn plötzlich jemand zu irgendeiner
Zeit aufs Mobiltelefon anruft.
Sie überlegen sich:
"Gehe ich da jetzt ran?"
Dann haben Sie da effektiv
einen Regierungschef am Apparat
und überlegen sich: "Ist das jetzt
wirklich der oder tut er nur so?"
Es waren aber tatsächlich
die Regierungschefs.
Das zeigt einfach,
wie gross der Druck war.
Da hatte die Person am nächsten Tag
vielleicht eine Medienkonferenz
und wollte ein Update bekommen
und sagte sich dann, ohne
die üblichen Wege einzuschlagen:
"Jetzt rufe ich den direkt an."
Diese Diagnosegeräte
stehen in Labors und Spitälern.
Sie analysieren Speichelproben
oder Nase-Rachen-Abstriche
vollautomatisch in 90 Min.
Für den Corona-PCR-Test musste Roche
nur das Testmaterial neu entwickeln.
Die schnellsten Geräte
schaffen 3'000 Tests pro Tag.
Darum spielen sie bei der Bekämpfung
der Pandemie eine grosse Rolle.
Die Diagnostik war bei Roche immer
das Stiefkind neben der Pharma.
Jetzt sind Sie der Star. Wie ist das?
- Das ist megacool.
Früher musste ich
den Leuten immer erklären,
dass auch die Diagnostik
wichtig ist,
um für die Ärzte
die Grundlage zu schaffen,
aufgrund derer sie
Entscheidungen treffen.
Aber jetzt weiss jeder,
was PCR ist.
Neben dem Imagegewinn
kurbelt die Pandemie den Umsatz an -
wohl auch langfristig, denn Roche
hat nun viele Maschinen verkauft.
Stehen diese einmal in einem Labor
oder Spital, ist es einfacher,
auch mit anderen Tests und Reagenzien
Geld zu verdienen.
Es gibt viele Screening-Tests
für Infektions-
oder auch Krebskrankheiten,
die auf diesen Systemen laufen.
Unsere Chance ist, dass wir jetzt -
wir nennen es das Menü -
die Anzahl der verschiedenen Tests
auf diesen Instrumenten erweitern
und damit natürlich
noch einen besseren Beitrag
an das Gesundheitssystem liefern
und gleichzeitig
unsere Marktposition
und unser Geschäft ausbauen können.
* Stimmengewirr *
In Rotkreuz werden die Diagnose-
maschinen auch zusammengebaut.
Jede einzeln von Hand.
Nach Ausbruch der Pandemie
lief die Produktion auf Hochtouren.
Viele Mitarbeitende mussten
monatelang auch samstags arbeiten.
Auch der Konzernchef machte Über-
stunden - mehr als für ihn üblich.
Hin und wieder gibt es Probleme,
an die denkt man beim Einschlafen
und wenn man in der Früh aufwacht.
Ich beneide die Personen,
die zumindest behaupten,
dass sie völlig abschalten können.
Ich hätte gerne diese Fähigkeit,
aber ehrlich gesagt
habe ich sie nicht.
Der Umsatz der Diagnostiksparte,
zu der auch die Selbsttests gehören,
explodierte wegen der Pandemie.
Das kompensierte den Einbruch
bei den Medikamenten.
Und was kommt jetzt?
Jetzt kommen noch Sitzungen
zu laufenden Forschungs-
und Entwicklungsprojekten.
Da geht es jetzt
um die längerfristige Zukunft.
Und da dürfen wir nicht dabei sein?
- Nein.
Aber in zehn Jahren
treffen wir uns dann wieder
und schauen, was wir
auf den Markt gebracht haben.
Severin Schwans Ziel:
die Nummer 1 bleiben.
* Langsame, pulsierende Musik *
Das Tinguely-Museum.
Imagepflege am Standort Basel.
Roche hat es vor 25 Jahren
der Stadt geschenkt.
Dieses Engagement
ist ganz im Sinne der Familie.
Tinguely war ein Freund
Maja Sacher-Hoffmanns.
Er hat z.B. zum 80. Geburtstag
meiner Grossmutter
ein Feuerwerk gemacht.
Er malte auf Holz den Namen Maja
und befestigte
viele kleine Raketen daran.
Dann durfte wir das anzünden.
Ich war damals 18 oder 19 -
ich war sehr aufgeregt.
Ich durfte herumgehen
und das explodieren lassen.
Das war schön und lustig.
Roche finanziert auch
den Betrieb des Museums
und investiert
in den Erhalt der Kunst.
Im Schauatelier werden Werke
von Tinguely aus aller Welt
wieder in Gang gebracht.
Dieses lag mehrere Jahre
in einem Keller in Paris.
Haben Sie auch einen Tinguely?
- Nein, ich habe keinen.
Ich habe ein paar Collagen.
Die machen auch Probleme
mit dem Licht, mit Zersetzung -
gerade mit Filzstift,
mit Filzschreiber.
Eine wurde mit Suppe geschrieben.
Suppe?
- Ja, Oxtail.
* Lachen *
Das waren Briefe, die er geschrieben
hat und die ich behalten habe.
In der Familie
sind auch recht viele Sammler.
Sammeln Sie auch etwas?
Kunst oder ...
Ich habe meinen Weinkeller.
Und der ist nicht für die Ewigkeit.
Der Wein ist eigentlich
für den Konsum gedacht.
Kunst und Kultur werden nicht nur
vom Konzern gefördert,
sondern auch von der Familie selbst.
Die Roche-Erben gehören zu
den grössten Mäzenen der Schweiz.
Sie können es sich leisten.
Es ist erstaunlich. Diese beiden
Türme sind schon erstaunlich.
Mit einem Vermögen von rund
35 Mrd. Fr. sind Hoffmanns und Oeris
die zweitreichste
Familie der Schweiz,
hinter jener von
Ikea-Gründer Ingvar Kamprad.
Vom Reichtum der Roche-Erben
profitiert die Stadt Basel
im grossen Stil.
V.a. die Oeris,
die immer noch in Basel leben,
betätigen sich hier als Mäzene.
Sie haben viele Museen finanziert
und Sammlungen gespendet ...
... unterstützen die Musik-Akademie,
den Zoo, eine Kirche,
die Universität und Onlinemedien.
Sie betreiben einen Jazzcampus,
eine Alzheimertagesstätte
und günstige Wohnungen
überall in der Stadt.
Dazu kommen viele andere Engagements.
Kurz: Die Roche-Erben prägen Basel
bis heute mit geschätzt 1 Mrd. Fr.
Maja Oeri etwa spendete 50 Mio.
für den Neubau des Kunstmuseums -
aber nur unter der Bedingung,
dass auch die Stadt
50 Mio. beisteuerte.
Im Museum selbst
hängen Bilder der Familie
wie die weltberühmte "Brennende
Giraffe" von Salvador Dalí,
die zur
Emanuel Hoffmann-Stiftung gehört.
Die Bilder der Stiftung,
die nicht ausgestellt sind,
werden im Schaulager aufbewahrt.
Bei dessen Einweihung trat Maja Oeri
ausnahmsweise öffentlich auf.
Ich entwickelte die Idee
für eine neuartige Kunstinstitution.
Ein Lagerhaus,
in dem die Werke unverpackt
und richtig installiert
gelagert sind.
Die Basler Roche-Mäzene
sind verschwiegen.
Fotos von ihnen
gibt es praktisch keine,
Interviews ebenfalls nicht.
Das gilt auch
für Sabine Duschmalé-Oeri,
Jörg Duschmalés Mutter.
Sie spendet Millionen für klassische
Musik, etwa für die Musik-Akademie.
Erst kürzlich willigte sie ein, dass
zumindest ihr Name sichtbar wird.
Das ist auch Teil
dieser Basler Kultur,
dass man sich selbst eben nicht
gerne immer im Vordergrund sieht.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie das für dich ist,
aber so eine Situation wie die jetzt
ist auch für mich nicht ganz einfach
und nicht etwas, was ich
in meinem Alltag und gerne mache.
Genauso geht es den anderen
Mitgliedern der Familie auch,
und deshalb bleiben sie lieber
ein bisschen im Hintergrund.
Die Ausnahme der Regel: Gigi Oeri.
Sie ist durch die Heirat mit Andreas
Oeri in den Roche-Clan gekommen.
Mit dessen Geld
finanzierte sie den FC Basel
und brachte ihn
an die Schweizer Spitze.
Legendär und von einigen Roche-Erben
nicht goutiert:
ihr Auftritt beim Gewinn
des ersten Meistertitels 2002.
(Originalton) Spiderwoman.
Gigi Oeri hat ihre Wette eingelöst
und badet mit der Mannschaft.
Seit ihrem Rücktritt beim FCB
ist auch sie kaum mehr in den Medien.
Und auch sie hat
eine Interviewanfrage abgelehnt.
"Man gibt,
spricht aber nicht darüber",
so eine Basler Redensart.
Dividenden
machen das Mäzenatentum erst möglich.
Die Erben
dürfen keine Aktien verkaufen,
wenn sie die Mehrheit an Roche
behalten wollen.
Aber Dividenden fliessen reichlich.
Roche hat sie in den letzten
34 Jahren ununterbrochen erhöht.
Allein dieses Jahr
erhielt die Familie 729 Mio. Fr.
Über 34 Jahre addiert,
wurden gut 10 Mrd.
an Dividenden ausgeschüttet.
Davon profitieren neben Basel
auch andere Orte.
Etwa Arles in Südfrankreich.
Ein 56 m hoher Turm
dominiert die Region.
Der futuristische Bau
hat 150 Mio. Euro gekostet.
Das Kunst- und Kulturzentrum
ist das Werk von Maja Hoffmann,
Andrés Schwester.
Sie hat es im Juni mit
Stararchitekt Frank Gehry eingeweiht.
Die Roche-Erbin
mischt Arles schon länger auf -
mit der Umwandlung
einer Eisenbahnwerkstätte,
mit eigenen Hotels im Städtchen
und mit einem Van-Gogh-Museum.
Die Mäzenin stösst bei der Bevöl-
kerung aber nicht nur auf Anklang.
Maja Hoffmanns Wirken in Arles
hängt mit ihrer Kindheit zusammen.
Sie wuchs mit ihren Geschwistern
in der Camargue
in der Nähe von Arles auf.
Vater Luc baute hier 1954
eine Forschungsstation,
untersuchte die artenreiche Vogelwelt
und setzte sich für
die Erhaltung der Feuchtgebiete ein.
Der Naturschützer gründete
mit anderen zusammen den WWF.
Gleichzeitig
sass er im Verwaltungsrat von Roche.
Für ihn kein Widerspruch.
Obschon es bei Roche gelegentlich
Probleme in dieser Richtung
gegeben hat, glaube ich,
dass ich mich nicht
für das Umweltverhalten von Roche
schämen muss.
Roche hat immer dafür gesorgt,
wenn mal Sachen passierten,
dass sie nachher korrigiert wurden.
Die Camargue ist heute
grossflächig geschützt.
Der Schutz der Natur
ist auch im Elsass ein Thema,
in der Petite Camargue,
8 km von Basel entfernt.
Auch ein Feuchtgebiet,
nur viel kleiner
als das Vorbild in Südfrankreich.
Luc Hoffmann hat hier
während des Biologiestudiums in Basel
Vögel erforscht.
Sohn André finanziert nun
eine Professorenstelle
an der Universität Basel,
die hier
eine Forschungsstation betreibt.
Wow!
Für die Nachhaltigkeit setzt André
Hoffmann viel Zeit und Geld ein.
Das fordert er auch von Roche.
Es gibt keine Nachhaltigkeit
ohne diese Symbiose,
diese Harmonie
zwischen Natur und Menschheit.
Und wenn es keine Zukunft gibt,
gibt es auch Roche nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, es ist einfach
eine Sache der Vernunft.
Wir müssen mit der Natur
ein Friedensabkommen unterzeichnen,
was wir bis jetzt
noch nicht gemacht haben.
Aber die Realität in der Firma
sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
Man sitzt hier
und schaut sich die Vögel an.
Das klingt gut, aber in der Realität
ist es ein bisschen härter,
weil nicht alles geht.
Aber ich sage es noch einmal:
Die Idee ist nicht,
nur über die Natur zu reden.
Die Idee ist, auch über Soziales,
über Menschliches
wie über ein Nachhaltigkeitsmodell
zu reden.
Und Nachhaltigkeit ist auch,
Erfolg zu haben.
Eine Firma, die keinen Gewinn macht,
kann nicht nachhaltig sein.
Allerdings ist der Gewinn sehr hoch,
mit Rekordmargen von über 30 %.
Hoffmann rechtfertigt das etwa
mit den hohen Forschungskosten.
Wir stehen jetzt im Flur,
und Sie sehen gerade
in die Laborwelt rein.
Kann ich noch einen Schritt
nach vorne gehen?- Ja. Gut.
Das ist jetzt so, wie der Lichtstand
sein wird - irgendwann im Juni.
Sie sehen also, wie lichtdurchflutet
und transparent es ist
und wie weit man sehen kann.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit
den Laborantinnen und Laboranten?
Müssen die Eintritt zahlen,
wenn sie hier arbeiten?
* Lachen *
Das müssen wir uns noch überlegen.
- Fantastisch. Unglaublich.
Am Roche-Standort
im aargauischen Kaiseraugst
steht ein Modell im Massstab 1:1.
Severin Schwan hat das Testlabor
schon mehrmals besucht.
Es soll später in Basel
zu Hunderten gebaut werden.
Ich finde auch die Holzverkleidung
in den Gängen schön.
Das gibt dem Ganzen
eine gewisse Wohnlichkeit.
Ja, das macht es sehr warm -
Sie erinnern sich an die Diskussion,
in der Sie sagten, die Ecken
seien für Sie die schönsten Räume?
Können Sie sich noch erinnern,
wo da die Lifte standen?
Da sagte ich,
es könne ja nicht sein,
dass gerade dort der Lift steht.
Da müsse das Labor hin.
Und heute
haben wir nun diese Labore drin,
diese Spezialsachen.
- Da bin ich aber wirklich stolz.
Ich werde in eine Ecke gehen
und die Aussicht geniessen.
Die Labors werden virtuell
und auch real aufgebaut,
um schon im Vorfeld
Fehler auszumerzen.
Das ist neu entwickelt. Wo kommt
mein Abfalllösungsmittel hin?
Herr Hoffmann sagt,
Roche müsse nachhaltig sein.
Ja, und dazu gehört
der Schutz der Umwelt.
Auch im Labor
gibt's viele Möglichkeiten,
mit nachhaltigen Materialien
zu arbeiten.
Ja, wirklich fast ausschliesslich
mit nachhaltigen Materialien.
Das Einzige, bei dem wir jetzt
an die Grenzen gestossen sind:
Wir haben viel Holz im Labor.
Das gibt es
in der ganzen Schweiz noch nicht.
Da muss Lack drauf,
der funktioniert -
der ist nicht ganz so nachhaltig.
Ah, Luft.
Roche wird vom Dow Jones
Sustainability Index
fast jährlich zum nachhaltigsten
Pharmakonzern gekürt.
Kritik gibt's trotzdem,
etwa wegen Severin Schwans Lohn.
Er verdient jährlich
rund 15 Mio. Fr. -
so viel wie kein anderer Manager
in der Schweiz.
Wir reden über Nachhaltigkeit.
Ist Ihr Lohn nachhaltig?
Ja ...
Ich kann nachvollziehen,
dass es da Diskussionen gibt.
Was meinen Lohn angeht,
ist natürlich v.a. wichtig,
dass der Vergütungsausschuss
des Verwaltungsrats
unabhängig darüber entscheidet.
Letztlich macht der das Gleiche,
was ich ja
mit meinen eigenen Leuten mache.
Ich schaue mir die Leistung an, ich
schaue, ob die Resultate stimmen.
Das ist die Grundvoraussetzung
für hohe Löhne.
Herr Schwans Lohn
ist nicht nachhaltig,
denn ein Mensch
kann gar nicht so viel verdienen.
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Was ist die Antwort?
Nachhaltigkeit heisst auch,
Talent am richtigen Ort zu haben.
Wir stehen mit anderen Firmen
im Wettbewerb
um dieselben Talente.
Da gilt
ein internationaler Massstab.
Das ist nicht nur
ein gesellschaftliches Problem,
das ist etwas grösser.
Wenn Sie diesen Lohn absegnen,
ist Ihnen dabei wohl?
Oder denken Sie auch,
das sei ein bisschen viel?
Ich glaube, wir können froh sein,
dass Herr Schwan
CEO unserer Firma ist.
Sein Lohn bereitet mir
da keine schlaflosen Nächte.
Ein anderer Kritikpunkt:
die hohen Medikamentenpreise.
Ein Arzt entdeckte per Zufall,
dass das Krebsmittel Avastin
auch gegen Altersblindheit wirkt.
Roche brachte darauf Lucentis auf
den Markt, das praktisch gleich ist -
ausser beim Preis.
Eine Spritze Lucentis
kostet 1'800 Fr. ...
... eine Spritze Avastin nur 40 Fr.
Und das bei
nachgewiesen gleich guter Wirkung.
Doch Avastin darf offiziell
nicht eingesetzt werden,
denn Roche hat nur Lucentis
für die Behandlung
von Altersblindheit absegnen lassen.
Die Krankenkassen
dürfen deshalb nur Lucentis vergüten.
Das Medikament wird in Europa
von Novartis vertrieben.
Die italienische Wettbewerbsbehörde
wollte sich das nicht bieten lassen
und verurteilte Roche und Novartis
zu je 90 Mio. Euro Busse.
In Frankreich
haben Roche und Novartis letztes Jahr
aus demselben Grund eine Busse
von zusammen 444 Mio. erhalten.
Beide Bussen
sind noch nicht rechtskräftig.
Und in der Schweiz hat es seit 2008
in Bundesbern neun Vorstösse gegeben.
Gesundheitsminister Alain Berset
musste schon mehrfach Stellung
nehmen, letztmals im Frühling.
Ist das einfach ein fauler Trick?
Es sind
zwei verschiedene Medikamente,
die unterschiedliche
Entwicklungspfade genommen haben.
Jedes hat sein eigenes Investment.
Entsprechend sind sie
als unterschiedliche Medikamente
auf dem Markt.
In Italien wurde Roche zu
einer Busse von 90 Mio. verurteilt.
Wie erklären Sie sich das denn?
Ja, wir sind mit dem Urteil
zunächst nicht einverstanden.
Es gibt eine Reihe von Ländern,
die das anders sehen.
Ich muss das zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Aber
der entscheidende Punkt ist,
dass die Privatindustrie
einen Anreiz hat,
in Innovationen für die Zukunft
zu investieren,
damit sich
so wie in der Vergangenheit
das Gesundheitssystem
ständig weiterentwickelt
und dann auch Patienten
von solchen hervorragen Innovationen
wie Lucentis profitieren können.
Im Fall Lucentis/Avastin
dachten Sie nie,
Sie hätten da
einen Fehler gemacht?
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Den Standort in Basel
baut Roche seit Jahren mächtig aus.
Direkt neben den beiden Bürotürmen
entsteht ein riesiges
Forschungszentrum mit vier Gebäuden.
Das höchste ist 114 m hoch.
Das finde ich echt super.
Wo ist Herr Bossard?
Ich muss ihm wieder Nachhilfe
in Architektur geben.
Ich muss Sie da wieder
auf ein architektonisches Detail
aufmerksam machen.
Schauen Sie sich mal die Fenster an.
Ich finde diese Fenster
unglaublich elegant
in ihrer Klarheit und Filigranität.
Wir haben alte Gebäude
aus den 30er-Jahren,
die genau dieses Element auch haben.
Sie hätten Architekt werden sollen.
Ja, vielleicht.
Das hätte mir sicher Spass gemacht.
Aber das Tolle ist: Bei Roche
kann ich das jetzt sogar ausleben.
Roche investiert 1,2 Mrd. Fr.
in das neue Forschungszentrum -
mehr als für
die beiden Bürotürme zusammen.
1'800 Personen
arbeiten hier künftig in Labors,
die Severin Schwan zuvor mit der
3-D-Brille virtuell angeschaut hat.
Ja, das ist das Herz der Innovation.
Irgendwann laufen die Patente
auf unseren Medikamenten aus.
Dann brauchen wir neue Medikamente,
und die werden künftig
in diesen Räumlichkeiten entstehen.
Aber das ist
wie die Nadel im Heuhaufen.
Wenn man immer am Ball bleibt,
wenn man immer an der Spitze steht,
dann klappt es halt hin und wieder.
Aber Sie haben schon recht,
es klappt nicht immer.
Darum setzt Roche stark
auf Übernahmen.
Allein seit der Jahrtausendwende
hat der Konzern 50 Firmen gekauft,
für über 100 Mrd. Fr.
Der grösste Deal:
Genentech 2009 für rund 50 Mrd. Fr.
Mit der US-Biotechfirma
wurde Roche zur Nummer 1
im lukrativen Krebsgeschäft.
Und mit der Übernahme
der deutschen Boehringer Mannheim
wurde Roche weltweiter Marktführer
in der Diagnostik.
Der Erfolg von Roche
hängt so stark von übernommenen
Firmen und deren Produkten ab.
99 % der Innovation
im wissenschaftlichen Bereich,
im medizinischen Bereich
passiert irgendwo
ausserhalb von Roche.
Deshalb ist es für uns entscheidend,
diese Innovation,
die in akademischen Institutionen
und anderen Unternehmen
auf der ganzen Welt entsteht,
auch in Roche zu holen.
Die Kehrseite der milliardenteuren
Übernahmen: hohe Medikamentenpreise,
denn die Kaufsummen
müssen wieder eingespielt werden.
Wie lange dauert es noch?
Nicht lange.
Das ist die letzte Station.
Ja.
- Okay.
Ich sehe gerade, dass ich
um 15 Uhr den nächsten Termin habe.
Sehr schön, vielen Dank.
Die riesige Investition in Basel
ist ganz im Sinne
Jörg Duschmalés und der Familie.
Basel und Roche - eine Symbiose.
Der Konzern kann praktisch
ohne Widerstand Türme bauen.
Im Gegenzug profitieren die Stadt
und die Bevölkerung
von hohen Steuereinnahmen,
von 11'000 gut bezahlten Jobs
und vom Mäzenatentum.
Basel ist schon sehr zentral
für unsere Familie.
Auch André, der seinen Wohnsitz
nie wirklich in Basel hatte,
bezeichnet sich als Auslandbasler.
Basel und Basler Werte
prägen unsere Familien schon auch.
Was sind das für Werte?
Das leichte Understatement,
ein bisschen zurückgezogen zu sein
und doch stolz auf das zu sein,
was man ist und erreicht hat.
Bescheidenheit und Understatement Ð
was für die Erben gilt,
gilt nicht unbedingt für Roche.
Der Pharmariese
hat sich ein Denkmal gesetzt.
Und der Roche-Clan,
mittlerweile in fünfter Generation,
lässt keinen Zweifel daran,
dass er Basel mit dem Konzern
noch lange prägen wird.
* Fliessende, drängende Musik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2021